we're live
awesome guys i'm uh
doing this on facebook too trying to get
this feed going
yup dope starting you know this
cool good to see you guys
aguero i don't even know who that is
hello
ramen okay yeah
i still don't know who that is
guys so we're going to wait a little bit
a couple a couple seconds here to get
going for some reason my
facebook situation isn't
isn't happening but hey i'll tell you
what
facebook sucks compared to youtube and i
got
um all my videos from pakistan got
demonetized
on facebook how crazy is that and i
don't know why i
i wrote to them and they just said you
didn't follow our terms and conditions
and i said
i looked at their terms and conditions
and there was zero
like nothing i did out of line
so who knows how that stuff goes ali
khan welcome thank you
moon thank you for coming moon is from
iran
detroit in the house islamabad cool what
a cool
international group karachi
i feel like i was just in karachi
because i was editing those videos
lahore what's up
mr gamer hi uk
lahore again manchester uk wow
a lot of pakistanis from around the
world i've realized um
well i always knew there are a lot of
pakistanis that lived in
new york and in the uk but i had no idea
how many
birmingham edmonton alberta
cool guys well i got the youtube going
the facebook is another story
give me one second guys we'll figure
this out but shoot me some questions
saudi arabia
sweet
jedha toronto wow we got a cool group
here
i can't keep up with all the messaging
that's awesome
uh peshawar peshawar what a city that is
you guys if you haven't been there
it's uh i i titled that
video the friendliest city and you know
sort of a arbitrary title right
but i have never run i mean
everywhere in pakistan was super
friendly but i've never
run into anything like that in my life
where it was literally
take a step someone comes out and says
hi the next step someone says
come in for tea next step the next step
that was an amazing um that was an
amazing shoot and i was a little nervous
going into it i was definitely a bit
nervous
because i've i've followed the
geopolitics in the region
for a while and you know the northwest
the kpk you know sort of has this stigma
and
i had wanted to go to peshawar for a
long time
and you know i got on i got out of my
place
and i started walking down the street to
make an intro like i always try to make
these intros right
so here's here we are in peshawar we're
going to get into the
downtown i forget how i started it and
then i walked out to the street
and there were these those guys on the
superbikes these guys on superbikes
oh dino thank you man really cool of you
appreciate that
so these guys on super bikes
and one guy i don't know who ever saw
the peshawar video
um will be able to tell one guy was like
he lived in in the states
he he spoke perfect english and he's
like
yeah you can come with me and so that
was the start of of
peshawar right like on the back of
someone's crotch rocket
and so instantly my mind was spinning
like okay first of all
i was a little apprehensive even though
i knew it was fine
to go there when i did i was a little
apprehensive
and then i'm on the back of a crotch
rocket
going into the center that was a wild
journey that was
that was like um i felt really alive
so in these shoots in pakistan i felt
every day i felt super alive
because one
i'm really out of my uh normal world oh
thank you for the donation i didn't see
who that was but thank you
when i'm out of my normal world and
that's one thing like going into a new
place
in most of the videos i didn't have you
know i went off alone
without things set up because i want to
keep it as authentic
as possible for you guys like i want you
guys to feel like
those first feelings that i feel i don't
want it to be all
cookie cutter and like easy i want it to
be a bit of a struggle right
um so in those videos where i go out
into the unknown let's say
obviously i'm standing out i'm a big
bald you know white cia looking dude
that's what people call me at least and
i get out there that's one thing but
then putting the camera
in right in my face and just walking on
the streets and then all the attention
comes in and most of it's super positive
but i also have to keep you know my
awareness of what's going on and try to
figure out where i'm going what i'm
doing and in pakistan
i mean this this worked tremendously
well like uh
what a cool country what a cool people
um
[Laughter]
i'm not gonna respond to that one if you
guys saw that
okay i'm gonna answer some questions
guys shoot some questions
um peter will you ever visit the family
in ukraine
okay that's off pakistan but yes um so
guys
this is blaze bob ladies bob thank you
this is a family
uh guys if you look back if you're
interested in outside of pakistan
in my youtube history the first thing i
did was i lived with a family in the
south of ukraine
in the countryside they were
refugees from war and uh it was an
amazing journey that was crazy it was
like
it was a life shaping experience and
that led me into pakistan it led me into
all these other journeys really
to make videos out of them um bob
i i will visit them again i don't know
when though
i don't know when that time will be
um what okay what part of pakistan did i
find the most amazing food okay i'm not
gonna
claim that i'm any any connoisseur on
the food
that um i'm no authority on the food
because honestly
these days of shooting i was almost
making a video every
tanner thank you appreciate that i was
almost making a video every
day and i started two weeks prior to
india and india is not easy travel
either it's like the cities are hectic
and
polluted and loud and it's they're
stimulating but you're drained at the
end of the day so
um when i got to pakistan
i got into lahore first and that food
that punjab food it
pretty much carried over from the punjab
region of india from what up from what i
tasted so it was similar
i had a little bit of knowledge about it
punch up food was fantastic with that
said the street food i had in karachi
was
was amazing the food up in hunza
uh this local um was it ox i think was
ox they do
everything grass-fed like it's a really
healthy environment
that was amazing peshawar
i'm trying to remember what i ate there
but i pretty much the food was good all
over the place
my only my only thing about pakistani
food which if you're not
pakistani might take some adjustment
sometimes things can come in pretty oily
dino thank you for that appreciate it
appreciate it
really cool you guys um i miss the major
places of karachi
okay um akbar
thanks for saying that and here's why
my style of vlogging and travel videos
is not it's actually getting more away
from going to the main sites
so my whole my whole shtick the whole
reason i do all this is because i want
to connect with the people and i want to
i want to keep it as authentic as
possible so whenever i go to like
tourist sites
usually it takes away from that a bit
right and i feel like there's plenty of
content online if you want to see like
the main tourist sites
plenty of guys do it right um
hold on one sec i got some facebook
issues just trying to get this going
here
um so yeah it's like
i i never i always feel like i can do
better for sure
and i can show more but what i'm trying
to do my style has changed before i used
to try to go to i'd go to a city
and i'd shoot it for three days and then
um i'd get back
to to where i live i live in key view
crane
i'd get back to edit and i'd have all
this this footage right and i'm like
okay i got to make a story out of this
but it's got to be youtube length which
isn't like more than 25 minutes you're
going to lose people
out after 25 minutes for sure um
and i got all this all this footage and
i got to compress it compress it
compress it
and then it's i don't know i just think
this this style is better with like
more running gun on the street putting
some b-roll in like some flow
edit sections but mostly it's like on
the street interactions
so my long roundabout answer is
yeah i missed a lot of karachi it's a
massive city i can spend weeks
shooting videos there for sure so for me
and i'd say you know i'm biased
obviously because of where i come from
i'm not
i'm not from there i'm coming from the
outside
and for that reason it's like the stuff
that's fascinating is that busy hectic
street life
that's the stuff that's interesting for
me
and for you it might not be
right because you're like you're living
there it's like what do you what's
what's cool about that well
when you come from a part of the world
and even in ukraine it's uh
we don't get any street life like that
um
it's fascinating and so it makes good
video too it makes interesting video
but i do understand the problem of it
doesn't show a full picture
of a place and that if somebody knows
nothing about karachi for example or
pakistan and all they see is that
they're going to think oh
that's that's really like really poor
place or
whatever the thought might be like oh
it's so tight and crowded
so i usually try to like couple it
like show the rich and and show like the
busy crazy street life
i didn't do it right in uh in karachi
and to truth be told that was like
that was day 30 that last karachi video
i don't know if it shows in the video
but i was destroyed i was just like
30 days of shooting videos straight
traveling around this part of the world
i was dead and uh i gave him my best but
yeah i i agree i could have gotten uh
some of the wealthier stuff better okay
i'm gonna go through some questions here
karachi is a hard city brother you got
balls going there
it's the bass drum man karachi is the
bass drum
for those that haven't been like uh it's
definitely not for everyone
karachi will hit you harder than
anything else
at least of all the places i've been in
the world
karachi is uh
it hits hard but it's nice it's friendly
that's what's cool about it
like if it if it if the people weren't
friendly that would be a brutal place to
go to because it's just
it's intense
okay don't listen to any negative
comments
yeah you sort of have to do um grow a
thick
skin in this in this platform
um i try not to they're always going to
be people
haters especially when you're okay if i
make a video on ukraine
i can have russians that are you know
russian nationalists that don't like it
vice versa or a good one would be
iran or saudi arabia i've made videos in
buddhist countries both audiences
there's
a minority let's say that
are going to [ __ ] on the other one no
matter what and of course india pakistan
so there are two types in the pakistani
um content
two types of people right indians that
comment
some which i give a lot of respect to or
like
wow i didn't know it was like that love
to pakistan would love to visit someday
something like that right
and so that guy is going over the
propaganda
he's reaching you know the olive branch
and he's a peace lover and he's he
realizes that you know the narratives
that are spun
are mostly [ __ ] and then there's the
other type that you know is just going
to be
nationalistic hardcore you know
pakistan is the the root of all
terrorism and uh
our salon thank you appreciate it um
pakistan's the root of all terrorism
and uh you know as negative as you can
get right
he's like two types of people from india
that would comment on
on the videos and i was surprised
actually how many indians did
compliment in a positive way uh
okay but the question was negative um
comments
yeah some most of them don't get me
occasionally someone will get me under
under the skin a bit
for sure depends the mood i'm in um but
i
i really give my all in these videos
it's like it's not for the money
it's like i'm i'm actually
like just paying my expenses now through
youtube which is cool
it's like a cool point i got to uh
at the moment but it's not it's not
really bringing anything in
outside of my expenses so
yeah the comments is that just goes with
the territory
no no one's not everyone's gonna agree
with me and i hope and it's good they
don't i
the world should not be like me
everyone's different
um but i can't imagine getting on
someone's platform and just going crazy
in the negative space
i just can't imagine wasting my time
doing that
uh difference between india and pakistan
except
religion oh guys i'm thinking
i'm thinking i'm going to make a video
thank you
whoever sent that five dollars i
appreciate it
i'm thinking i'm going to make a video
on
what do you guys think do you think like
the differences are
the similarities and differences between
pakistan and india
i'm thinking of doing something like
that for next week that would be
probably my final video on pakistan
um okay the differences
okay so i've been to india three times
pakistan this was my first one
first my my first trip to pakistan
i would say
okay they're super regionalized
countries both of them have that in
common
for sure if you're in the mountain in
the himalaya
or gilgame or you know down to karachi
or
or mumbai or something these are
different worlds within
a country like very diverse countries
they both are very different
diverse within themselves the
differences between the two
india seems to have more color
in it like just in your everyday life
you're seeing more colors
i think that's india is probably the
most colorful place
i would say pakistan is more
here these are big generalities
not everyone obviously but the big
generalities you have to speak in
generalities with this stuff
pakistan is um it's uh
people are more curious for sure
like they they want to know your story
more i would say maybe because they get
a lot less tourism
taurus but i also think it's an islamic
thing i think all
muslim countries look india is what 20
islamic but
it's sort of a thing that carries
through a narrative through all muslim
countries is
it just it's in the culture to uh
you know hospitality i would say
um pakistan has
like no i think i met one scammer
one guy tried to rip me off with a taxi
in pakistan islamabad he sucked oh
thanks peter appreciate it
um but other than that there was no like
touting there was no
scamming that was nice india has
depending on where you're at this last
trip in india i didn't deal with much of
it but
two trips before i dealt with a lot of
that and it depends where you're at
other differences um
we'll start with that those are some
pretty big ones
there's a lot of common ground that i
got to say i'm not just trying to be uh
diplomatic here there is a lot of common
ground between the countries
okay i'm from peshawar to do
stay safe i am safe guys i am in kiev
ukraine this is where i live with my
wife
the reason i get this question a lot
you're american but why do you live in
ukraine
a few reasons um
one i made a decision a couple years ago
that i really want to start
it actually happened slowly but i really
want to start making this content in the
world right
and i i run a business that i sold in
america
and i could run it from my computer so
this opportunity opened up i visited a
friend here actually had a couple
friends here
enjoyed it and then it was just this
opportunity that came about like
okay um i can actually do this
and now i'm hour and 45 minutes
systemable instead of
12. i'm uh the middle east is super
close
even pakistan isn't crazy to get to now
like so
this geography here is like keeps me
very much in touch with the world and so
i'm just really getting started
with making content i sold my business
in december
sort of like the last six months let's
say i've gone much more all in
and now i've got some momentum and i
really want to i want to push this
content so
being here is like super beneficial for
accessing the world i don't remember the
question was i'm sorry
um but there are plenty more so let me
let me get into these
pakistan zinder bod learn that like
minute one
in the country that's a good one
uh peter should more people
come to pakistan do you think it can
become a tourism spot
i think i think anyone that's curious
should go to pakistan like it's um
i think what's missing a lot in the west
and i think a lot of pakistanis that
live in
in the uk or us or wherever might say
this that have left
is they they miss that connectivity on
the streets maybe that
that like soul that real vibrant
not knowingness and not planning stuff
out and meeting with friends late into
the night it's not saying it doesn't
happen
in other countries but pakistan is a
very authentic
place that hasn't gone full west style
yet
and that's what's admirable so you
always like what you don't have and for
me that's what's interesting
and so i think that's what's interesting
for other
westerners coming from the us or western
europe or whether it's like okay you can
get into a culture and it's
it's not so much about transactions
some random guy with a machine gun is
going to invite you for some tea and you
laugh together without speaking a word
stuff like that i think that is is like
really rewarding travel
try to capture my best on the camera so
yeah it has a space pakistan definitely
has a space for more tourism
but i wouldn't sell it is like you know
some people got on the karachi video and
we're like
you know you should show the shopping
centers and stuff and yeah i should
show that that exists but i don't think
anyone's going to go to karachi for
shopping like they'll go to dubai first
or
you know miami or something so what
pakistan
has to offer the world is one
not and there's no order here but one
like
beautiful landscapes thank you for that
donation
two of those thank you guys both of you
appreciate it um it has beautiful land
like it has a beautiful landscape like
it has mountains it's got the sea
it's got desert it's got a lot going on
that respect cuisine is very good
uh the number one thing would be the
hospitality like the openness of the
people
and the like how warm it is in that
respect
so those type of tourists now your
average american going to pakistan don't
see it happening they've been
conditioned look they're the
taliban's going to get them the second
they get off the plane and it's going to
be super dangerous
the way the the way the news cycle works
and people's thoughts about country is
like
no matter if things have changed like
karachi six years ago is a different
karachi today than today right
it's not totally safe today like stuff
happens
but versus six years ago it's way better
it went from like the
fifth most dangerous to like the 96 most
dangerous in the world
so what often happens is people are
stuck
in like the last bit of information they
received about a country or a place
and so the last anything anyone hears in
the west about pakistan unfortunately is
going to be negative and that's why
i'm making this content is like here's
an alternative voice
and let me show you what i'm talking
about um
so it's going to take more of an
adventurous person let's say
from the west to go to pakistan at this
point in time
but how this stuff works is like vlogs
like this
people go they have a good experience
they go back they tell people
you know gains momentum all right
two places in pakistan we should
definitely visit as taurus okay i would
say
hunza valley blew my mind that was i
knew i did a little bit of research on
it
i actually would like late at night
in like college years be looking at
you know researching hunza valley and
swat valley just curious to these
of these random places in the world
that was amazing though that that was
like really impressive so i'd say
definitely honza
ah then the rest is it's it could go
either way it could be uh from what i
saw lahore
offers a lot uh i know i pronounce it
wrong sorry
lahore uh peshawar
and karachi again if you want to feel
like the ultimate intensity in life
go to karachi but okay so i gave you one
location hunza
okay how do i distinguish peshawar from
other cities
it is um i talked about this a bit
earlier
i'd say the friendliness is at like
another level
and that doesn't discredit oops guys i'm
trying to get this facebook going
that doesn't discredit the friendliness
in in
any other part of the country like it's
uniform throughout the whole place
but peshawar is at uh next level
and pashtun people there you can feel
the difference
like the quality of pashtuns they're
very
they're very passionate they're very
passionate and i
probably could say that about everyone
in every group in pakistan right
but i think they're at the top with that
um i think they can be i think they're
known for this
i didn't come up with this there can be
your best friend or your worst enemy
right like if you're on the good side
like
you're our guest you're fully taken care
of
but if you're if you're on the bad side
i think it could go uh bad really
quickly so
as a tourist just be cool
it's pretty easy like just be respectful
and cool
and i think anyone that's going to
pakistan into
peshawar is going to be a more
open-minded cool person
rowena i think i said your name rowena
thank you so much for that
and thank you whomever else i didn't
thank you on um
the donations it's it's very cool of you
appreciate it
female perspective in pakistan that's a
tough one for me
um gogi thank you it's tough because
well i'm not a female obviously so i'm
not i'm not in those shoes
um but if you're asking me my
perspective on
how i think it is for females there
uh you know i don't i don't really have
a right
uh right to say you know what i mean
it's not my culture
and i'm not going to come in and tell
you how it should be
you know i i hope i don't come across
like that in my videos and i
really try to not be that person because
that's annoying when people come to the
states and they're like well at home
it's like
it's like this and we have this and like
okay
that's that's great but um
you know what i'm saying does that make
any sense i think so i'm not going to
judge i'm not going to tell
people how their culture should be but
traveling as women i mean
i'm sure you guys all know there's some
female vloggers that go to pakistan and
travel and
so yeah
guys i'm still trying to get this
facebook you know facebook absolutely
sucks so hard
and get this and we're just going to
take a little break because i'm trying
to get this facebook going
i had like the the pakistan series did
really well on facebook
and they demonetized it
and so i reached out to customer service
what's the reason for demonetization
oh here's our terms and conditions i
read through their terms and conditions
i wasn't out aligned with anything
every swear that i you know weren't many
but they were like
beeped out or like the sound was off for
him
nothing out of line and all of that
demonetized
yeah which sucks okay guys i apologize
i'm just trying to get this
you know youtube is the is the the
better platform
for sure okay
let me get another question i'll say
this once
sue facebook yeah they
i don't have those resources but it's a
good idea
um johnny sense say it once
i'm just gonna say it once this live
stream
i got called that multiple times every
day from all demographics from all
ages let's say from
nine year olds up pretty funny
am i fasting no you know i would totally
do it if i was
in that world if i was in the islamic
world and everyone was doing it
i'd like to do that i think it's a cool
thing i i ramadan
i really respect it i think it's uh good
to go without things for a while
and it seems like there's a very good
collective
like connected time
with families and friends and like you
guys deal without things
you know no eating all day and then
everyone gets together at the end of the
day
i think that's really cool and just
going without things that we become
accustomed to
i think there's a lot in that
okay
okay what do i think about islamophobia
damaging the tourism
look ignorance people are going to be
ignorant if they
i don't know what you do for that like
my content is definitely not going to
tap into some ignorant person they're
not going to want to sit there watching
me walk around the streets
right i think the content that's
probably more effective with that for an
ignorant person is just like
a two-minute video here's the top five
cool things about
pakistan maybe that would
tap in more but ignorance is ignorance
like you're not gonna especially when
you know people get older you're not
gonna be able to
convince them of of really anything
right
so the islamophobia thing i've
my first time in the islamic world was
maybe not the first but the second was
2008 i went to syria because i wanted
i was actually really interested in
talking to iraqis i didn't want to go to
iraq because it was a war zone
but i knew a bunch of syrians had come
over the border to damascus and i wanted
to learn
like what was going on there i wanted to
know the story and uh
that's when i really realized like how
hospitable
it's the it's so funny how this works
right the countries with the
let's say the shittiest political
relations with the us
like iran for example or syria are the
countries that have the most
hospitable welcoming and
open people so it's it's it's insane
right it's a good thing to be
american in iran right and if that in
probably the most
like look i've had no problem anywhere
as far as getting along with people
um open doors connecting
it hasn't been an issue anywhere but the
place that would be
the lowest on that scale would be the uk
right and that's the closest political
ally
with the us so the islamophobia stuff
it's just
uh it's it's annoying let's just say and
i don't i don't live in the states and
in whom i'm around
doesn't think that way i'm not dealing
with it directly
uh but i get it i get
why you know people have zero exposure
to the islamic world they only receive
negative information
it's always based in fear politicians
use i mean
look things have happened between the
islamic world in the western world
there's no doubt about it that that
exists geopolitically but what people
don't understand is
uh the islamic world hates radical
freaks
like 99 of them right so
it's just it goes down to a
a personality type right they're
warriors everywhere
in every country around the world that's
just
how the species works and some have
better access to do worse things
let's say okay
compare india to pakistan guys i think
i'm going to do a video on that i would
love
maybe after this live stream i'll look
through no i will look through all the
messages
for sure um but i would love any topics
you guys have like
again it's going to be probably
comparing contrasting india pakistan
because
people have asked but anything in that
space
um please let me know what you're
thinking
okay how is the tea in pakistan i don't
recall it too closely except the green
tea the kava
and peshawar which was great really good
tea
but i'm living i live in ukraine
and it's very strong tea culture so as
far as black tea
um i don't remember anything that stood
out more than here
how westernized do i think pakistan is
really good question
uh
so any of the big cities you have
serious western elements you can go to
subway sandwiches in lahore
um
[Music]
what demographic what percentage of the
population is in that world i
i don't know i'm guessing maybe 20
maybe 15
i like i really admire cultures that
have
retained their identity despite
globalization or westernization it's
it's admirable some countries
lose it completely as they run
you know towards what they think um
you know towards the western ideology
and there's great stuff in that but
there's also some
some bad points in it too so
uh i i think it's i think pakistan's
retained its uh
authenticity for the most part from what
i saw
i saw one message go through here about
where do i want to visit
next i was going to be in in lebanon
right now lebanon in syria
that was the that was the next trip
but it's not happening now
obviously
did i like the north of pakistan for
sure
i really want to go back and um go to
swat valley
in other valleys in the mountains for
sure
okay there are no snipers in inner
lahore walled city or local travel
companions said there are snipers
the alleyways i couldn't stop laughing
comments
okay he got a lot of uh
let's call him hate messages firstly
uh a deal super passionate super
knowledgeable about his city some people
don't agree with some of the things he
said
now the snipers i think he was blowing i
think okay sometimes his english wasn't
he was using the wrong words i think he
meant to say like
this is sort of a controlled area but he
i also said you know
keep the energy high let's let's flow
through this thing and i think he got
charged up and we're we're really having
a good time together
and maybe he was trying to
you know snipers was the wrong word for
sure
um he actually got in trouble like
it's it's sad uh he got his tourism
license
revoked for six months some of the
mullahs
and some of the police were on him
hardcore the police brought him in
he's had to deal with all sorts of [ __ ]
from that video and i had to remove the
sniper part i had to remove
and uh another part i had to remove
for the mullahs thank you dina
and that's a really tough um no analysis
but it's gonna it leads into something
i'd like to talk about it's like um
that's a real tough part about this type
of shooting i don't want to jeopardize
anyone's
anyone's life right i'm leaving they're
not
and so i want to keep it as authentic
and to the ground
in in real as possible
but then there's sometimes something
said
you know do i leave that in the video or
not he said it
he said it that's how he feels i'm not
saying it's right or wrong
it's not what i do in my videos i'm not
telling what's right or wrong i'm just
guys let's go in on a journey let's see
what these streets are like
and this you don't have to agree with
what people say or not but this is what
they're saying so that's what it's like
on the streets right that's
that's the audience most of my audience
gets that
so it's hard though and you know i dealt
with that in saudi arabia too
people want to express their opinions
and say things and uh
you know a deal i after i i could see
the problems that were going to come in
that video and i said man
you sure you sure i can leave that in
you sure
are you cool with that
so there's a lot of work behind the
scenes you don't see where i'm i'm
there's a lot of stuff i gotta leave out
unfortunately sometimes i gotta leave
stuff out
you realize making content
how much of the narrative the the
content maker controls
like there were some kids in karachi
that were starting to throw rocks at me
right they like i got out of there i
didn't make much video of it but i was
just
it wasn't a place i probably shouldn't
have been and it wasn't liara it was my
last day there
and i got out of there and it was no big
deal
they were more joking around but still
rocks are rocks
they weren't throwing with anger they
were just sort of like throwing
sort of aggressive little shits do i
leave that in or out
it will change the mood of the video
right so
it's it's sometimes a challenge
okay
facebook is totally missed out here
because
i have not got this live stream going
let me see if i can get it going here
hold on one second guys
um creator studio that's where i gotta
be
live stream there we go
i'm really not good at this to be honest
not a tech guy i was setting this stuff
up today
i thought i needed different software
and all that stuff okay
go live
i'll give another try okay do i want to
go to
afghanistan um
that's one of those i really don't know
the situation on the ground there i'd
have to do my research
i know there are parts of the country
that are fine they're parts that aren't
i don't want to i don't want to do
anything stupid
like my point is to show these parts of
the world
to the west like the reason i do all
this is growing up in america i was told
the world's a dark
dangerous hole don't go anywhere except
maybe
italy and france or england the rest of
it
it's dangerous why would you do that and
so i was the rebellious type and
you know now i gotta do it and so we
never traveled growing up never took a
family vacation my first trip was at 24
right before my 25th birthday i saw
countries in the world that had these
terrible labels and
i was just like my whole world changed i
was
brought in by really cool people had
amazing experiences when i went home to
tell people
they were like looked puzzled thought i
was crazy
a lot of times and uh i was like okay i
get it now okay so all we see in the u.s
is just
bad press negative you know people are
busy well people don't understand a lot
of times in the world
um look if you're your average american
you're working
you're working a lot you're you've got
kids your jug
life is busy life has many things going
on many moving parts
way more moving parts than most places
and so time is uh
is spare time is not something most
people have and so if they're not
highly interested in something why are
they going to like
really true you know to understand a
place like pakistan is uh
that's a full-time job right there
there should be a phd in that
understanding pakistan
just the regional differences the
cultural differences
the history the political climate it's
there's so much
i've i've always i've saved
flirted with it i've gone in but i'm no
scholar on pakistan by any stretch
and that trip just like it taught me a
ton but i realized how much i don't know
still by doing that so the average
person just has no
clue in the uk or the state or anywhere
really
out of the region they really just don't
know and so when all they see is
something negative
you know you're uh you're you're an
average say you're an average guy a
middle-class guy in the u.s even though
the middle class is sort of going down
and you want to take your family on a
vacation you're going to have to be
really cool and adventuresome and
open-minded to go to pakistan
because the conditioning the
conditioning the conditioning right
um again i lost the track of what what
the
the question was but yeah most people
just don't have an understanding
really and just the regional differences
there
it was it was unbelievable
why didn't i make it to uh chanterelle
chatrell i think you said
ali i uh i did the best i could you know
you can't go everywhere if you go if you
try to go everywhere you go nowhere
i think you get what i mean like if i'm
there for half a day then i really don't
experience anything and i i pushed
pretty hard at pakistan i was there two
weeks
lahore islamabad hunza peshawar karachi
i couldn't fit another drop in and
making videos every day at the end of
the day i'm
downloading all the footage i'm backing
up all my footage i got these hard
drives that i'm like
protecting like
with my life because i had all my
footage from india full series there if
i lost that stuff i would have been
devastated
um peter this is from fahed
my relatives and i have lived in america
we know the reality of american
americans but these pakistanis
who live in pakistan are mostly ignorant
about america
and americans okay america is a tough
one because america sneezes and everyone
sort of feels the effect right
unfortunately
or fortunately however you want to look
at it so
people have an understanding of of of
the soft power
and the hard power in pakistan they get
the hard power right because
there's been conflict in the past and
the soft powers the brad pitt
or or instagram or whatever else all the
platforms we're using right now you know
so people are familiar with america in
these senses
what people do not understand about
america i would say most foreigners that
i've met is
a they don't get the regional
differences at all so think pakistan
if you're pakistani you understand how
different peshawar
is than you know
defense area of lahore is much different
right
and then they also don't understand that
everyone's not
rich that's that's a hard one it's the
richest country in the world right well
it's got a mega population of
uh 330 million um
look the living standards are high
but something like
don't quote me on this but it was like
sixty percent of the country don't have
fi they don't have five hundred dollars
to scrape together
like 500 liquid in cash uh
so put that into perspective
right nobody's traveling on that if
you're living like that you're not
traveling you're not going anywhere
i think a lot of people don't understand
either the
complexities of such a individualized
uh society and there's there's pros and
cons to it i'm in
i'm definitely a product of the culture
you know i'm going out in the world
alone without the group if i didn't have
the upbringing
i i had i i doubt i would be doing that
you know if i had like
super connected place where i was from
with like this massive family
would be very alienating to do what i do
uh
so there are pros and cons to it for
sure
but i think very america is very very
very much misunderstood
that's a good point you bring up um
differences indian pakistan i'm gonna do
a video on that because everyone's
asking
can you tell us why pakistani vendors
don't let foreigners pay
for their food
look i think it's just like uh they
don't give any tourists
it's in the culture it's it's an islamic
thing to take care of the guest
and then pakistan just puts that on
steroids
i think thank you thank you for the
donation pakistan really ramps that up
so some pakistanis might be able to
chime in here and tell you better but
um it comes from the heart i think
i think they have this thing um they
have this thing in iran
called tarouf teruf is when
you know someone offers you something
and you're supposed to say no
and then he offers you again and you're
supposed to say no and then he offers
you and then you say yeah
something like that it's really it's
sort of like a custom of like
of of uh giving i hope that makes sense
pakistan is just like here you go
like and you're supposed to take it from
my experience it wasn't
like no don't give it to me it would be
seen as a
almost offensive i've tried that a few
times and they're like no
no take this
what camera am i using to record my
vlogs so
i like to keep things as simple as
possible and also
all the experiences is as real as
possible so if you go into someone's
face
in like a tight place with a big dslr
and a big lens
it's going to change things it changes
the dynamics a bit so i go in
i might lose some quality in the audio
and with the um
you know the adjustability of the lens
and that sort of stuff but i just going
with the gopro
hero 8 the thing is amazing it has its
limitations
i go with the eight and then i go with
my iphone so the
whenever i make these sequences like
these edited pieces
from a car or something it's just done
with my iphone iphone 11.
keeps it simple and
the gopro you can just go in like i'm
holding it here
sort of flow around with it if i as long
as i have eye contact with someone
they're really not paying much attention
to it
okay guys let me do some more facebook
is not working but
i hate to say it to my facebook audience
like it's um
it sucks it doesn't work but facebook
facebook just sucks it on all fronts for
me these days
if you just got on this chat they
demonetize
all of my pakistan series
and their customer service will not help
out so if anyone knows anyone at
facebook
ask them please um
would i advise to visit pakistan alone
or with a group it depends on you
um i'm an alone
type guy i'm i'm fine with having
moments alone
i like the freedom and flexibility i
want to meet someone if they invite me
another home i can
i can take up the offer or whatever
depends who you are if you want
if you want to not think and uh
you know not deal with the the grind
that it sometimes turns in whenever
you're traveling on your own in another
country
there's going to be parts where it
grinds like the you know the transport
isn't where you thought it would be
you're trying to find things you're
navigating different places if you don't
want to deal with that then go with the
group
for sure but sometimes those are the
moments that
the the really cool stuff happens
okay here's a good one uh sony rock so
in islamabad you saw the discrimination
against minorities and you
you belonging from the west posted this
on your channel
um i.e difference of accent and religion
uh have balls to say something on this
now
sure i've got balls thank you sophia um
look like i said earlier i'm all about
presenting what i come into i'm not
saying it's right
i'm not saying it's wrong this guy
wilkar
said in this neighborhood the these are
the christians and this is the
underclass
in this neighborhood one of the problems
with condensing hours and hours of
footage into
say a 20 minute video is some of the
context gets
left out and i think i don't fully
conveyed the context
of that properly so
were were they in let's call it islam i
didn't really
it didn't i wouldn't even call it islam
but they call it their islam
it was primarily christians there yes
there are christian churches
there yes i think it's super
complex the history between uh
um of the religions in pakistan i was
told there are three type
like i'm not an authority on this so i'm
not claiming to be there were three
different
uh types of christians and the types of
cry i'm not talking
catholic or protestants but like almost
casts of christians
in pakistan and that cast was
they call them the underclass there and
then there are christians that are big
business people and wealthy and whatnot
so i didn't
yeah sometimes i really don't uh
get it how i want to let's say um
so did i have the balls oh thank you
thank you for the donation
yeah i have the balls to go into
pakistan alone and and like
dive deep on the place it's not always
easy either
so yeah i'd say i definitely have the
balls to explain that
um that was the best of my knowledge i
didn't again some of the
things i don't totally get right
but what i want to do is bring you guys
into what i see
with the least amount of filters the
only truth is in through your own eyes
that's that's that's the reality and
then it's how you perceive what you see
anyways
right um but
when you watch tv the news whatever
i mean you're not going to get
the on the street feel so much i'm
trying to i'm really trying my hardest
to capture that
and what people say is what i record and
i'm not saying it's right or wrong it's
it's up for it's just
it is it is what he said could it be
right or wrong
maybe i'm not i'm not a journalist don't
confuse me for a journalist i'm not
i'm not going deep on a investigation
let's say
i'm just showing you like this is the
content i always want to see i'm like
what is it like there
i remember when the iraq war started
and it was all over the news this is
when i was a kid it was 1991 the first
gulf war
it was all over the news and then it was
gone 72 hours later and i was like what
is it like there what is it like on the
streets what are people saying and
how does it feel and i'm not talking
like an interviewed
you know approach i'm just talking like
like what are they even driving around
in cars and like
you know are there many people crossing
the streets that sort of stuff so that's
always been the stuff i've been
interested in um
favorite pakistani oh that's a funnier
question i'll answer favorite pakistani
city
i don't have a favorite they're all like
i'm not trying to be diplomatic either
if i wasn't to live in one
of the ones i saw if i was to live in
pakistan i live in hunza
for um the second would probably be
islamabad not because it's the most
dynamic and interesting it's because
it's
it's quieter than the other big cities
okay why am i bald
that one i don't know god
god decided
okay so many good questions here guys
um
they're flying through peter is
unavailable
unavailability of alcohol or bar is a
big problem for tourism
pakistan what do i think i'm all about
it because i don't drink anymore
and i stopped drinking five years ago
and
no judgment against drinking if if you
drink
like like zero judgment i'm not like
anti-alcohol guy
but for me life is better without it
so i i really do enjoy those cultures
where alcohol is not out on the surface
like the whole social gathering point
isn't around a bar
that's nice i think that um
quite often the west overemphasizes that
like
okay we want to talk and hang out with
friends that we have to drink
uh i'm over that personally
um so i do admire i really admire that
it's not okay alcohol is there
right people drink behind closed doors
i'm sure there's some underground bar
scenes
okay okay lll alcohol is easily
accessible
yeah i'm i'm sure it is when i was in
saudi arabia
they were you know it's very you know
it's it's restricted obviously but no
it's behind closed doors
i even saw a couple
10 30 in the morning in their car drunk
from a night of partying
and it was like uh
it just seemed like uh you know you can
outlaw whatever you want but people are
people they're going to do what they
want to do
congrats to my wedding thank you thank
you last week
we we tied the knot officially
went to the offices here in ukraine
signed off
it's official hard to plan a wedding
these days that's for sure
like no one's going to be able to fly
here
meeting up so we'll have a wedding one
of these days probably next year
um what do i feel pakistan india i'm
going to answer that in a video
uh summer uh um
are you planning to go to summer still
many places between hunts and islamabad
that should be explored yeah there
there are so many uh veins up in the
mountains there thank you asif
appreciate it
so many veins of valleys and mountains
there's
yeah i would love to spend a lot of time
in that region
alden thank you
okay guys a lot of good questions i'm
just trying to diversify them here a bit
do a documentary in the history of
pakistan and the mughal empire
here's my problem this uh mir khan
that sounds like a great documentary i
would watch it but
making documentaries i did a doc series
and it's not even a full documentary
just a series it is an ungodly amount of
uh
i hope i'm not offending anyone it's a
saying we have in the states it has
nothing to do with religion but
it's an ungodly amount of editing and
sitting on my ass
in a seat in front of my computer and i
already feel like i do too much of that
i've tried to simplify my editing so i'm
not because i really am not a natural
sit in front of the computer type of guy
and this has really
made me it's turned me into that not
naturally but it's turned me into that
to some degree
the editing so for example one of the
videos you saw
in the series i go out with the gopro
in a video right and there's a stress to
it
every time seriously there's like i'm
stressed
because i don't know if i'm going to get
anything again i want to keep this stuff
spontaneous i could look there's some
some areas like in lahore i had a guide
set up that was one where i had a guide
sometimes i have people set up
but a majority of it is
i want to bring you guys through the
adventure along with me
we're in this together your surprise is
my surprise
and again i don't know if i'm gonna come
flat on my face with that
like i honestly thought the the second
video i did in
peshawar i honestly thought i wasn't
gonna post i'm like uh maybe it's just
not that interesting maybe there's just
nothing in this
uh when i went to this market and i
posted and people seem
people seem to like it so i never know
but the the process is usually like
go out maybe recording upwards of three
hours
of footage and then i gotta cut that
down
no one's gonna watch no one would watch
three hours it'd be boring unedited
footage
so i got to cut it down to the best
parts but in a way that it's flows well
enough
where it's not so jumpy all over the
place it's annoying
sometimes i get it better than other
times sometimes it just works out better
than other times
thank you thank you for the five dollars
appreciate it
um that's the whole thing it's just
it's serendipity and i i think there's
so much content on youtube now and
there's
so many really good cinematographers
and really good cameras and lenses and
after effects on on the computer and
they can color
color correct everything and and tweak
out the video so much
i'm not going to compete in that space
because i just don't have the patience
or probably the skill to do it
um my strength is going in
to the unknown and and finding something
in that
um so
it's it's actually it looks like all fun
but it's quite stressful a lot of times
i'm like
because i don't want to post crap i
don't want to post some videos let's go
ah
nothing in it but then i got a limited
time in a place
for example in india i did a series in
india before pakistan
i did two videos in delhi
both weren't that good i just didn't
post them
i just didn't work out
um cody good to see you brother
all right guys
let's get into some more questions
did you not explore karachi very well
why
well i went to lyari don't tell me
that's not some radical exploration
that was that was i was a little bit
fearful going in there i'm going to be
honest i knew the neighborhood had
cleaned up a lot
when i went in in there it's a big
neighborhood and i felt like
walled in there and i had to find
that guy in the in the white robe
massoud
he totally saved me because he was on it
he's like i'm gonna find these rappers
and we're gonna you know we're gonna
make this happen and if i didn't see him
who knows what it went into
but coming into that neighborhood it's
poor right and so it looks rougher
do i know if it's rough or not not
really so
i dug deep on that in karachi give me
credit for that one
then the second day i went into i
started in a park
museum and then into the center
look if you're if you're an outsider
the center is sort of where you go to
cities and then i finished up at clifton
because i knew that was a nicer
neighborhood it was a nicer neighborhood
a wealthier neighborhood
thank you thank you for the donation
so i hit a few different things in that
video is there like 20 other videos i
could have gotten out of karachi for
sure and are there malls in karachi
i did mention them but i didn't have the
time to go
all over the city i only had a couple
days there and i did the stuff that i
found interesting
again it's perspective what's the stuff
that's interesting those old
british colonial buildings the lively
streets all the colors all the action
the noise the activity the bass drum
beating
or some mall in a subway sandwich
franchise which exists everywhere
you know i get the point though i get
that
i should show you know in pakistan
people
people don't know that stuff exists
there and so i
i do regret not showing that a bit
better
but look i went pretty deep in karachi
for my limited time
i do need to return there are many more
stories to be had
for sure in all of these places really
more poverty india or pakistan
say there's more wealth in india it's
just a much larger economy i think more
they're more you know like ambani right
he's one of the richest guys in the
world
but as far as being in mumbai or delhi
or uh
or or lahore for example it's i don't
know i think it's pretty similar
actually what i did notice in pakistan
where there are less um
open-air sewer drains which was nice
right like the sewer lines are buried
better in the city
in pakis in the cities in pakistan
better than india i'll give it that for
sure
uh i saw a comment here on village life
i lost it but um
i would like to get into that deeper
that takes time i just i had two weeks
there
i had to see my it was a month-long trip
india two weeks pakistan two weeks and
then i had to see my
girlfriend at the time now now wife
um we were
we were gonna be abroad for the winter
in
spain and portugal in warmer weather and
i had to get as much as many videos as
possible
and then be with her it's a balance
doing this stuff
she's super cool like uh
super supportive helps me with all these
videos
and and very very she's the best with
this stuff
but there's a balance in life right
you could spend months in pakistan
getting videos easily
and if i was single and younger maybe
i'd do that but at this stage now i want
to go in
i got 10 videos that's enough for now
[ __ ] india oh ah you tricked me
that's not cool hey you can do the
nationalism stuff you can do the hate
stuff
my platform's not the best place for
that seriously
there's so many better places for hating
on nations
than what i do because if you honestly
watch my content with an open mind
you're not going to hate on people and i
get it
i get it it's an easy place to dump
pain politics or race
or nationalism any of that [ __ ] it's the
easiest place like if i'm hurting inside
if i'm pissed off
dump it on a people dump it on a country
that's easy peasy
but the reality is you gotta do the
inner work and i'm saying i'm speaking
to whoever said
f india like you have to do the inner
work
and um is the politics
terrible between the countries and the
histories yeah yeah all that i got that
like i get it i get it and
it's not easy but i met people in both
countries
that were so curious about the other
country they're like oh man i wish i
could go to pakistan so bad i've always
wanted to go there i can't get a visa
and i heard pakistani say that about
india too and
these very very nationalistic types if
you if you
if you raise okay check this out say
instead of being raised in pakistan they
were born and raised in india
and conditioned that way right they saw
their news
they learned hindi that same person
would hate pakistan
right it's just like growing water and
feed them
in another country and it doesn't matter
the country it's just the ideology it's
the way of thinking it's the level of
development
that's my take on it i might not make
some friends with that but
i mean easy for me to say i live in a
very diverse country
and it's not like canada and uh in the
us went to war
it's not like a canadian guy killed my
granddad and i'm pissed at him
but it's interesting to see some
some countries navigate this space way
better than others for example vietnam
vietnam as an american you go there it's
like
wow we my country killed four million of
their people
four million they won the war we lost
fifty eight thousand they lost four
million
place got completely uh oblivious
obliterated monsanto chemicals
everywhere
and there's zero animosity against me i
thought they would hate me
for sure why wouldn't they zero and then
you go to the balkans
and it's like i'm speaking in
generalities here not everyone obviously
uh someone's like you know your granddad
killed my granddad therefore i hate you
you know it's so
this is not the best place for hating on
other like
that's what fox news and cnn and all
that stuff is for
honestly just for venting
the pain
okay media and politicians have created
hate between indian pakistan people
i think you're asking have they yeah for
sure
there's so much money to be made off
that right that's
even the the media itself makes its
money off
uh the conflict look humans are
naturally gravitated towards negative or
shocking or alarming thing that's why
sometimes in my two youtube videos like
kicked out of velocity no i said
expelled from balochistan i didn't want
to say that i just like
but i just want to say like going to
check out some boats
you know in balochistan no one would
click on it
and so our minds are just wired to go
towards what's the shocking or what's
the
alarming thing and so yeah the the
conflict between the two countries
is a big big money maker and media is
one of the big benef
beneficiaries of that for sure
unfortunately
where were there any bad experience
you've had in pakistan
and that you didn't share in your vlogs
ah nothing too bad i mean i had a guy in
islamabad he
ripped me off um
taxi guy i got in how did it work we it
was on it was the uh it was like the
local uber i forget what it was
we got in and he instantly wanted more
money from me thank you busan
i think i said your name right um he
wanted more money from me instantly
and i was just like uh no no and he was
a total ass and he followed me around
some kids try to you know threw some
rocks at me there's a few weird things i
mean
look no no place has all good people
it's impossible
anyone thinks that that's possible is
just not is
smoking something or not on planet earth
there there are bad people everywhere
and um
you know some countries are easier with
people than others and i'd say pakistan
is at the top
as far as easy
to connect with people hospitality
you know navigating in english look i
was mostly in cities
and i'm sure the countryside would be
different but navigating in
english pretty easy
okay why didn't i visit india occupied
cashmere i would like to
i would like to it's all a time thing
comparison karachi and mumbai
they're really different actually but
that's it that's a good idea
what about someone who loves traveling
and can't afford plane tickets
can i travel by roads uh depends the
country i guess you're referring to
pakistan for sure
i was actually super surprised when i
took a
was a blah blah car or taxi from
islamabad to peshawar
it was like a three-lane wide
new highway i had no idea that would be
there
you know going to the kpk i'm thinking
like
off of some dirt road right that's how
little i know
but we're going down this mega highway
so yes getting around in pakistan
buy vehicles is easy the only reason i
flew
well i had to fly into the mountains but
then i flew back towards karachi was
just
time it was it's just a time issue
plan to visit pakistan again in the
future for sure i don't know when but
i would like to uh you know i need to go
to some other countries
i was going to go to beiru i was
supposed to be in lebanon right now
in syria um but i would i scratched the
surface of pakistan i'm well aware of
that for sure
compare the three big cities islamabad
karachi lahore that's a good that's a
good idea that's a good video idea
for sure gonna miss watching your videos
and packs thank you
i'll have one more at least coming for
you
all right guys i'll probably put another
10 minutes in on this
um this has been fun it's a little weird
talking in a glass to be honest
uh you know the human connection is
better
but how cool is this technology where
how many people are here
6 38 i don't know if that's in total or
at the time but
and we're all talking about pakistan
that's cool like
how cool is that
balochistan is so pretty better than
texas if you search
here's my take on the better and worse
better it just depends who you are and
what you like
thank you i think that was cody
he just splashed the cash
thank you appreciate it all of you all
of you
donating all of you with comments all of
you who've watched the series
it's really cool it look this work it
all looks social it all looks like
you're out traveling
most of it is actually behind a computer
editing
and like forcing myself to edit
sometimes i just don't want to edit and
i just have to like
force myself down
okay littering situation in pakistan in
india that's like uh
yabrowski thank you cody that's um
that's one of my pet peeves to be honest
i hate the litter i hate the litter
stuff
it's it's i get if there's nowhere to
put it but when you're in nature and
someone's just
hunza i gotta say was pretty clean from
what i remember i don't remember much
litter in hunza valley but um
i'm not one to judge it's not my culture
but that that's
look if your dad litters you litter
right isn't that how that works
or your dad does something you do it
either emulate your parents or do the
exact opposite but most people emulate
so how do you how do you break that i
think it comes through education
did i have a visa problem and travel
restrictions so
to to travel
to travel to pakistan on an american
passport you need to do
get a visa beforehand
i forget how it was it was a process
where as if i went on my italian
password
excuse me italian passport it was a
simple thing online
and i printed off a piece of paper and
got in the country that way so i chose
the italian
passport for that but if you have an
american passport like it shouldn't be a
barrier it's not that hard
i remember traveling a long time ago in
central asia
countries like tajikistan back in 2002
that was
pulling teeth together like really most
countries now
um it's easier than what it was
that was one guy in tashkent
that was either drunk or fishing giving
out
the uh the visas and i was trying to do
it from uzbekistan
it took like two weeks of constant calls
peter say nothing for two minutes with
the eyes closed
can't do it i can do it but not on a
live stream because then probably half
the people will go
um experience at pakistani airports
peshawar one super
super nice cool cool officials and uh
karachi one slow as dirt like the
bureaucracy
but not many flights going in and out
very chill
that's it this back to uh the question i
had earlier about differences
i would say the authorities in pakistan
as a tourist are way cooler than india
this last trip i didn't have any
problems in india but usually when you
put a uniform and a badge
on those cops in india they're they're
they're
they're more a-holes for sure with the
the rangers were
cool as they come the police were all
cool
maybe it was my um experience maybe i
got lucky
but overall through and through like
super welcoming
very very cool people
what country did i prefer india or
pakistan they're both so different
both so similar and i they're both
they're it's like what do you like pizza
or uh
or tacos depends
for what right india is a cool place
it's it's got it's um
it's got a lot going on it's very much
mixed up
and it's very much not like what most
people think
and the same can be said for both most
countries
all right
my favorite travel vlogger i
i cannot sit through most travel vlogs
and i don't know why but
the one uh
that i can is bald and bankrupt like
that's
he's really good at storytelling like he
puts his stories together very well
it's very interesting great great
personality so
uh that would be the one that i
i would watch a full full episode i'm
not trying to be a snob here i just i
don't know why i don't watch
i really don't watch full travel vlog i
don't watch my videos after i post them
after i post them it's done for life
i can't go back and watch them i don't
know why
pakistan pakistan tourism minister
should have rewarded me as a
you're an honest ambassador thank you i
don't think they would like my episode
to
the ship breaking yard though
that was part of doing that was to show
people that no i'm not getting paid by
the pakistani government to make videos
in pakistan
because there's no way they would
support that jay the man thank you
there is no way any government would uh
support me
to go to balochistan to
sneak into a shipyard and make a video
out of it
and just for those because i definitely
pissed some people off with that
i didn't go over any fences i didn't
pass anywhere that said no trespassing
once the guy was like you got to talk to
the boss i went to the boss um
i just i that ship breaking stuff is
fascinating
and i wanted but you know i felt like i
didn't get anything out of it and then
after i edited i'm like oh that's sort
of cool i honestly didn't think i was
going to make anything out of it because
i didn't get
really into the shift i just got into it
but i didn't get up into it
okay a few more here a few more guys i
have three computer i have a phone and
two computers my facebook uh
didn't work which sucks because i had it
i told the audience there
um and my phone camera is better than my
computer camera so i can't scroll there
so i got
my my wife's computer
scrolling too and i'm just looking for a
much different question
uh was the one city i would recommend to
americans to visit pakistan mr t
i would say what are you looking for mr
t
if you want big busy bossy [ __ ]
uh bass drum can't be crouched
if you want to get your proverbial ass
kicked
in a city karachi is the place like just
stand
uh in the center of the city for a bit
it's not a bad thing too i love that
stuff i love being put out of my comfort
comfort zone i love just the the chaos
and the
the noise and the action that's your
thing
thank you uh ako ako or akko thank you
if that's your thing then uh karachi is
a tough one to beat
uh lahore i really like the mughal
architecture that was
very very impressive to me in that old
city there and the guide
i was with on the second video there or
the third video
a deal go with meet up with him if you
can like he's
he's he knows a lot about the old city
and it's the descriptions in um his
descriptions and his info is in my
video description islamabad
if you want a quieter pakistani city but
if you're going to one city from the
states
it's not going to really that would be
the most comfortable place to go
um but you know yeah i think you go to
pakistan to be
you know to learn and be exposed to
you know a different world peshawar
it's adventurous uh that could be an
option too
culturally it's very deep there it's
just like well all these cities are
culturally very deep but
there's just uh there's so many layers i
look at uh
western you know like american cities i
love san francisco love
love love love san francisco but we're
talking
150 years ago was nothing really
two lifetimes ago the city was barely
anything
and uh you go to some of these cities in
pakistan you're like wow no that's
there's something in there you know you
see a door from
400 years ago or mughal architecture
it's it puts you in your place that's
for sure
cannabis culture in pakistan i'm sure
there is
i didn't i didn't come across it
how much did it cost
my trip um
i didn't add that up actually um
i think i think in total i think i was
paying like
35 and four some hotels are more
expensive let me think
um let's just say i was doing 80 a day
something like that maybe a bit more
van life doable in pakistan i think so
yeah
i think um the people would be cool like
they would be very open to it i think
why didn't you do what you did in saudi
arabia by asking
foreigners about the country it was
weird why did i do it
asking foreigners about the country i'm
trying to think when i ask foreigners
about the country in saudi arabia
they'll have an answer for you i'll have
to think about that
okay guys so many questions a lot of
india pakistan stuff will i become
muslim
don't see it happening no offense just
not a religious person
um pakistan zinder bad
learn that one that's a very famous
saying in pakistan a few foreigners
going there
victory to pakistan right
can i talk about walking over the border
yeah that was surreal
uh smh very interesting i love borders
because
they're somewhat arbitrary especially
pakistan india right there
there wasn't a border there at one time
they're drawn up by
politicians or lawyers usually or
politicians
and then when you have one like pakistan
or india and pakistan it's
you know there's there's a lot of
tension in that border
and so it's always super fascinating to
to come up
on it's because you like like
the geography is the same the earth is
the same
but you go from one uniform in one guard
and one set of colors and it's very
patriotic on both sides of that border
and then you step into this other world
and that all the world is like you can't
go back
it's done and now you got to adjust into
this new one
and i thought when i got into pakistan
when i i thought it would be much more
relaxed than india
in the sense that when i got into lahore
i thought it would be like
much more chill and less
less crazy it wasn't same in that
respect
like it was just traffic horns colors
lights
uh yeah
so that was that was really cool that
was one of the coolest borders i've been
across
i highly suggest doing it and that waga
border ceremony is
is epic it's it's really a performance
and if you can see it from both
sides most people can't
but if you can it's it's just cool to
see both perspectives and i did a video
on that if you haven't seen it like i
did a video on like
comparing and contrasting to both sides
of the border
body language problem with communicating
body language no not at all not not an
issue it wasn't like going to china my
first time and
all your body language is gone
what should pakistan work on improving
first garbage hotels food transportation
garbage hands down
would i ever go to pakistan again for
sure
how many people we got here 5.99 okay
i'll keep going a little bit longer
how often will i do live streams in the
future uh
do i plan to collaborate with other
youtubers this is my second live stream
i've ever done
so i don't do these well it's the second
one on on youtube
don't do these often and collaborating
with youtubers
yeah if it was the right person for sure
i would love to uh if it was the right
person the last thing i want to do
there's so much travel content now i
want to keep it
pure and authentic and
even if it you know boasts my views
let's say
but it goes away from what i'm about
then i'm not going to do it so if it's
the right person i'm i'm
definitely down
whose infrastructure is better in europe
pakistan
i said earlier the uh in the cities in
pakistan from what i saw
the sewer was under in a lot of india
in the poorer places it's not
um
look there's such especially india's
such a big country i haven't been all
over india i can't i can't say
speak credibly on the infrastructure
uh language did i have a problem with
communicate uh
language in pakistan now i mean urdu you
learn a few urdu words
and then in the cities at least and
especially in hunza hunza
get this hunza valley this remote valley
in you know if you're not from that part
of the world it's it's
in the middle of nowhere and i've never
been to a place where more people more
more
old people speak english i mean i'm
comparing with you know outside of a
native
uh native speaking country so if you go
to germany or
you know belgium or something more
people were more older people could
speak better english in hunza valley
that was a
mind blower to me so
that's a big benefit of traveling uh
pakistan
for sure
pakistan's safe for woman there are
other
female vloggers that go into depth on
this
topic um
they'll be a way better source for me
than me i can't i can't speak but i mean
i think it's i think you'll be fine
okay i'm getting a lot of the same
questions guys
um
i speak russian not that great basic
russian
uh italian no i did i never grew i
didn't grow up in italian it was
actually
frowned upon when i grew up speaking the
native tongue because you're american
now don't
don't speak italian that's isn't that
crazy that would be really cool
um
what insights did i gain from my trip i
try to explain these in
in uh in the videos
i try to go into cultural nuances
but to sum it up quickly i would say uh
the the the massive regional
differences in the the very diverse
cultures that are operating within the
country it's it's quite amazing it stays
together
and i know that's could be a touchy
topic right
but the fact that
the state is uh uh together for the most
part
that's that's surprised like with the
differences with the regional
differences
um and i always thought that about india
too i'm like how does india not
break apart okay there
are small examples but for the whole
right
because there's such differences around
the country
next country it's going to be it was
going to be lebanon right now but that's
that's not happening
okay guys i think i'm going to call it
it's been uh it's been a real it was
such a cool experience
traveling pakistan for the pakistanis uh
watching
you guys were awesome like a very
very beautiful hospitable culture for
the people thinking of going there
uh do your research like where what
what you're into you know you're in the
mountains or busy hectic cities or
whatever
um but try to get try to get some
different places in to comparing
i always like the the contrast in places
and then you can like
you can base something off something
else and you get all these different
perspectives pakistan's great for that
and the flights obviously now it's not
happening but when when things get back
up and running
uh the how many flights i take in
pakistan
two great easy
um good experience the airports are so
chill
they're relaxed there's no tsa
um shouting at you it's it's
it's very relaxed there so i would say
you know get around as much as you can
and thank you all who watch the series
uh if you watched it or if you just
watch part of a video thank you for that
uh i never know how these things will
turn out to be honest
i'm i'm pretty happy with pakistan
there are some things i wish i got
better there are some things i wish
i did differently
but overall pretty happy with it
so thanks again uh
have a good evening good morning
wherever you're at there's some guy in
oz i think that's up at
five this morning he said or six
if you're there thank you brother
appreciate it and
how do i shut this thing off oh i gotta
say
pakistan zinderbaad